this is lucy james reading full reviewer
heidi kemps
keep in mind that this review is based
on the 1.0 release of genshin impact
genshin impact delivers a large
law-filled
graphically lush world with nuanced
combat character building
exploration mechanics and co-op
cross-play across multiple platforms
at the most appealing price point
possible free
and while it succeeds admirably for the
most part it stumbles in a few key ways
that remind you that there's no such
thing
as a fully free to play game
[Music]
gen impact makes a great first
impression
the anime inspired visuals are inviting
and colorful and the fully voiced
nicely choreographed cutscenes give the
game the feel of a premium product
it also gets you going with the gameplay
very quickly thanks to solid control
design you'll be running
swimming climbing dodging gliding
fighting slimes and slinging spells just
a few minutes after the intro cutscenes
wrap
up and once your first additional party
member officially joins your posse
things start to get very interesting
as you'll start to learn the ins and
outs of the elemental interactions that
make genshin impact unique
each character and enemy in genshin
impact has one of
seven elemental properties tied to them
which greatly affects what they can do
for combat and
exploration while systems of strong and
weak elements are extremely common in
games
genshin impact takes things a step
further introducing unique and
interesting ways for multiple elements
to interact with objects
and enemies
starts with simple interactions an
object aligned with dendro that's nature
like a wood shield or structure burns
with damaging flames when exposed to
pyro attacks
while pools of water can be frozen with
cryo element skills or used as a conduit
for causing electro damage in an area
experimenting with other elemental
combinations will yield more interesting
results
setting an enemy on fire and following
up with an electro attack
overloads them with energy and causes
area damage
while using a windstorm can blow another
source of elemental damage like pyro or
hydro
elsewhere while augmenting its strength
you can swap between four
active characters with a tap of the
d-pad giving you the ability to
strategically chain attacks to great
effect
the system makes party formation
interesting do you double up on elements
for bonuses
or field a team of different elements
just in case you run across
unexpected challenges and puzzles where
they could be useful
it's a fun and creative system that adds
a lot of enjoyment to exploring genji
impact's world that and there's plenty
to do here too
even though many areas of tevat haven't
been made available to explore yet
there's still plenty to do and see there
are chests to find
teleportation spots to activate all
kinds of raw materials to accumulate
side quests to complete and big baddies
to try and slay
if you want to stop exploring and relax
a little you can try your hand at
cooking food
forging weapons and even conjuring up
rare items through alchemy
if you're feeling particularly
adventurous you can even explore certain
dungeons with others online using co-op
play
and thanks to cross-platform
compatibility it's easy to join up with
others no matter what they're playing on
setting up elemental combos with a team
of players is very satisfying indeed
you'll get more party characters weapons
and loot as you play through the game
normally but there is a way to get some
extra goodies
by opening up your wallet gentian impact
monetization revolves primarily around
gacha a japanese term referring to a
loot box style system
you spend in-game currency on a wish
that will get you either a weapon or a
new character and buying 10 wishes at
once
guarantees a character or weapon a
4-star or better rarity
while you can obtain said currency
in-game for free in various ways
you can also buy it directly with real
money you can also use real money to buy
upgrades like item sets or a battle pass
that yields better rewards for your
questing endeavors besides utilizing a
confusing currency conversion system
you buy genesis crystals which you can
convert to primo gems which you then
convert to fates to spend on wishes
the gacha can be very punishing if
you're going for the top tier gacha
rewards you're either going to need to
be really lucky
or prepared to spend a lot of time and
or money the drop rate for the coveted 5
star characters is a mere
0.6 percent fortunately every 10 wish
role comes with at least one
four-star weapon or character and these
are more than sufficient to take on the
game's tougher challenges
it's also possible to not spend at all
if you carefully save the fate and primo
gems you acquire in-game
you can still assemble a formidable team
with a 10 wish costing about 20 to 30
depending on how many genesis crystals
you buy at once opening your wallet to
try for the best stuff can get very
pricey
very fast despite this gen chin impact
generally manages to dodge a lot of pay
to win
issues even if you get good characters
and weapons you still have to learn to
use them well and gather materials to
improve their abilities which can only
be achieved through
gameplay and the items you can buy
aren't an immediate gateway to becoming
overpowered
however like many free-to-play titles
gentian impact is built around getting
you to invest time in the game every day
you'll need to explore to find hunting
and harvesting spots for materials
needed not only for crafting and cooking
but also upgrading your characters and
weaponry
and increasing your adventurer's rank
the adventurers rank in particular
can be rather frustrating especially
early on many features like co-op play
certain regions of the map special
dungeons and even the ability to start
crucial story quests are gated behind
certain ranked numbers which restricts
your play in an otherwise open world
adventure
while plenty of activities in the game
yield experience points for the
adventurer's rank it can be tedious to
spend time doing side quests and
exploring areas you're not particularly
interested in to open up parts of the
game
that you do want to see another major
issue is that while gentian impact is
certainly a very nice looking game
its world doesn't offer much that's all
that interesting to see the landscapes
dungeons and enemies are generic and
samey with little in the way of
interesting ideas or architecture to
make the world feel distinct
from many other anime inspired fantasy
environments
the character design has a similar
problem while the characters certainly
aren't unappealing
most of their designs don't really stand
out as being particularly striking or
memorable
one more important factor that might
turn players off is that
because developer mihoyo is located in
mainland china
genchin impact is subject to rules
imposed by the chinese government
regarding online chat which means
certain politically sensitive terms like
taiwan and hong kong
are censored in conversation during
co-op play while this is an issue that
affects all games from china
some players will understandably not be
comfortable playing a game that's
subjected to such heavy government
censorship
overall gentian impact is a solid game
hampered a bit by the restrictions its
free to play model imposes
the overall production values are high
and the core gameplay
is solid in particular the elemental
interaction system is a ton of fun and
gives the game a distinct personality
but while there's a lot to do having
several chunks of gentian impact gated
off until you've reached a higher rank
is an obnoxious restriction for an open
world game to have
and once you finally do see what lies in
those unexplored areas
it's often a bit underwhelming still
it's a solid start
and i'll certainly be interested in
seeing how genshin impact continues to
evolve in future updates
and this mascot what's the deal with it
hey that's even worse than being a
mascot